bienvenue à l'espace naturel sensible de
l'étang de saint paul un site préservé
que le public peut découvrir notamment
lors des week-ends nature la visite est
assurée par un écogarde qui nous fait
découvrir les plantes endémiques
présente sur cette zone humide
pamiers n'est pas une plante remarquable
de l'étang saint paul partent les quand
même très intéressante l'île de la
réunion parce que c'est un palmier que
déjà clé endémiques de la réunion c'est
le lataniers rouge
endémique savez les termes endémique
endémiques de la réunion c'est à dire
qu'on va retrouver cette plante
uniquement à la réunion ou bien
uniquement dans les mascareignes
depuis 1996 le département acquis en
fait 190 hectares autour de l'étang de
saint paul justement pour préserver les
sites la qualité des sites et les
habitats
et en la réserve s'est créée en 2008
donc la réserve qui est on va dire dans
la continuité de ces espaces naturels
sensibles
les temps occupe une superficie de 400
47 hectares en plein coeur de la zone
semi sèche du littoral ouest il zones
humides qui figure parmi les milieux les
plus diversifiés de lille ici seize
espèces animales sont protégées dont 7
endormi la réserve naturelle est un
sanctuaire pour ce patrimoine animal et
végétal
l'étang de saint paul est la plus vaste
et la mieux préservée des zones humides
on va dire des étangs littoraux des
mascareignes d'où la nécessité
effectivement de préserver mais de faire
connaître aussi de faire découvrir au
public dans un but justement de faire
prendre conscience aux gens de cette
richesse naturelle
qui est menacé et qu'il faut préserver
la réserve naturelle de l'étang abrite
des formations végétales uniques comme
cette hibiscus de l'assumer en gros la
move débuts à les jaunes va durer
environ deux jours
sua lab et après quand elle va tomber
ben ali de cette couleur
là c'est le capot quai ou qu'apporte ça
c'est son fouillis c'est une espèce
exotique comme je disais auparavant nous
avons
il n'y avait pas les tous les magasins
qu'on a aujourd'hui par contre nos
ancêtres récupérer ses fruits et
confectionner des ouvriers des matelas
pourquoi nous mêmes ne vote pas les
enfants peuvent pas tout le monde
voilà comme vous pouvez toucher quand ma
chaise ou
manuel au cours de cette balade les
visiteurs prennent conscience de la
fragile beauté diversité de cet espace
naturel
la découverte de ce milieu se termine
par un atelier original
comprendre la confection du papier à
partir du papyrus pays